muito bom de jogadores pra mim é uma
experiência nova
é uma experiência nova porque nunca
falar num telex
é uma experiência nova porque é muito
raro histórico dela sábado manhã em
importante é quando convidaram para
fazer aqui uma pequena fracção tivesse a
ver com o tema do meu trabalho de
investigação eu fui obrigado a fazer um
exercício e que acho que nunca tinha
feito um exercício era visitar todos os
trabalhos livres que são fish no sentido
tentar responder ao repto é como foi
dirigido traseiro uma ideia inspiradora
surpreendendo
eu fiz exercício e como podem imaginar
confrontei um conforto do fracasso nos
confrontamos também com dois desafios e
esse fracasso e fifa quer compartilhar
aqui contas puxar um pouco esse meu
trabalho desse trabalho que tenho
desenvolvido então vocês verão em si nem
sempre sobre temas muito leve muito
tranqüilos e muito pacíficos
o primeiro trabalho que realizarei
relacionadas com a gestão das carreiras
com experiências as pessoas sérias e
saber qual é a relação entre a
experiência de vida de alguém que não vê
e apresentações culturais que existem
acerca das idéias é fazer esse trabalho
em portugal e também um sangue no
contexto do sambe khan fica e viver
durante três meses no instituto nacional
de ceps situado na cidade baiana
mais tarde desenvolve um trabalho tem a
ver com experiência das pessoas como
usamos do ar
aquelas pessoas que imagina num acidente
de viação na argumentação suas vidas
ficaram paraplégicas ou tetraplégicas o
trabalho
cumpriria o objetivo de perceber como é
que se dá é a construção pessoal e
social de vida destas pessoas
um outro trabalho tem a ver com
experiência nos serviços às forças
armadas é que os soldados que tendo
combatido na guerra mundial a guerra
colonial portuguesa os quiserem tamanho
do outro aso as guerras de libertação
como é que foram suas vidas e vidas
marcadas pela guerra e mercados todos
ciência e esta esse trabalho diz muito
acerca do que é portugal não só sabe
mexe em 1974 no fim da guerra
portugal é o país com mais homens em
armas
a maior porcentagem de homens em armas
só o engenhão tem uma maior porcentagem
de homens em armas e assim vai o nosso
mito do país de brandos costumes
outro trabalho desenvolvido e esse mais
recentes têm a ver com a experiência dos
sobreviventes do desastre de bhopal
não sei se já ouviram falar do desastre
deus na índia em 1984 e foi o maior
desastre industrial da história entre
dezembro e janeiro e fevereiro estiver
seguir em bhopal uma clínica de
tratamento aos sobreviventes de desastre
porque xuxa qual ainda se mantenha se
preserva e que tenha uma ideia global
pode ser considerada como dizia um autor
em santíssimo em gracinha pode ser
considerada a capital mundial dos
pulmões destruídos
praticamente em bhopal toda a gente tem
asma uma grande percentagem de pessoas
têm a china como dizia uma pessoa como
eu entrevistava quando voltou para sua
casa deixando só parar um pouco nas
escadas por
você olha pra mim parece que eu sou
saudável mas a verdade é que nós em
bhopal
é como se tivéssemos em corpos morte e
portanto esse confronto entenda se
cuidar daquilo que as pessoas viviam e
sofrimento que carregavam foi muito
instigante nessa experiência que eu
tenho em bhopal e portanto a minha idéia
era trazer uma idéia inspiradora tentar
agregar tentar se escolher algo mais
abstrato ar algo melhor acerca de
trabalho ea verdade é que chegue a uma
conclusão não tenho nenhuma idéia
inspiradora surpreendendo pra vocês
poderia dizer talvez e isto não é dizer
muito que existe uma tendência muito
forte para que as presenças de teus
sofreram alguma vulnerabilidade corporal
é que os pés deficiência é que eu tenho
um corpo um determinado como diferentes
tendo a ser pactuada como tragédia não
pela tragédia do show histórico mas pelo
modo como a sociedade em que vivem e
produzem exclusão social para estas
pessoas
pessoas que têm menos voz pessoas têm
menos recursos e pessoas que
inicialmente são decodificados no fundo
nós temos pressa e podemos dizer o
sociedades que promissão ou por uma
ativa ea discriminação são os usuários
poderão uso dos seus princípios
naquilo que a inclusão das pessoas mais
vulneráveis diz respeito
e portanto este é o fracasso o desafio
com que um confronto e que o estrago é
de quando vocês viram frente estes
trabalhos desenvolvidos com pessoas que
muitas delas passaram por experiências
de sofrimento
o desafio não é um desafio fácil é que o
senhor depositário destes tons do tempo
que essas pessoas não eram da
generosidade nas suas entrevistas do
modo como que deixaram partilhar as suas
vidas
o desafio é que não torna outra o
sofrimento
o desafio é que não usa estas pessoas a
escrever livros para fazer filmes para
fazer umas foi não ter ex e que faça o
sofrimento dessas pessoas um instrumento
conserva em mim é que é unicamente é
minha vida e minha carreira quero que
saia e como é que eu tento vencer esse
desafio eu tenho que vencer esse desafio
achando que aquilo que eu posso dizer
acerca das suas vidas modo não posso dar
uma forma serena emissário da sua voz
pode ter o goleiro do modestamente
transformar um pouco as situações em que
elas vivem e pra mim então nesse sentido
faz aqui uma lembrança que no dia 3 de
dezembro
vamos comemorar os 30 anos do desastre
global e trinta anos depois o city onde
aconteceu o acidente morreram naquela
noite 8 mil pessoas morreram nos anos
conseguimos 30 mil pessoas e hoje em dia
há pessoas que sofrem essas escolas
pessoas procuram tratamento procurando
compensações pessoas perderam seus
familiares
trinta anos depois o cinto da fábrica
ainda não foi limpo
essas pessoas deverão vir água
contaminada até 2003
só em 2003 eles providenciaram água ou
ímpar é e continuam gerações a mexer de
crianças com problemas de informações
genéticas que decorrem desse desastre
portanto criamos lembrar esses três
exemplos seja em pensamento seja de
forma solitária manifestação como um
momento que nós esquecemos porque fica
longe mas que o fato deveria fazer parte
da nossa memória social e da nossa
lembrança
quero contar agora com outro desafio
outro desafio e com vara a questão das
era o desafio é de como é que um livro
com experiências que são tão distantes
experiências que estão fora do meu
contexto e não de constantes por que
passam algumas delas nem eua o sangue é
verdade é que todas essas experiências
nos confrontam com situações que não são
fáceis de generalizar
nós não podemos generalizar porque é tão
diferentes experiências que ficou cego
quem é cego da experiência que temos
vamos doar ou experiência quem ficou
contaminado por um gás tóxico numa noite
é tão diferente a vivência deficiência
em portugal ou na índia ou em moçambique
é tão diferente ter atrito ciência
quando se mexeu diretamente ciência no
momento da sua vida
preterido na guerra teria que denunciar
infecção outra querida noite em toda a
família morreu eu sou o único evento
são histórias particulares que não
permitem grandes finalizações mas a
distância que o fal tem a ver com outra
coisa não tem a ver com a distância
física da sua atitude dos gestores têm a
ver com a dificuldade que nós temos em
viver a vida dos outros e para fora essa
dificuldade em falar do corpo o corpo
provavelmente como é a última fronteira
jenny wolf dizer
acerca da pobreza da língua ela se
aplicava que o inglês tem tantas
palavras tão ricas que permitem falar
os primeiros pensamentos não ia permitir
lhe permitem imprimir o pesado é mortes
mas nesta língua inglesa tão rica eu não
encontro palavras para descrever um
calafrio a uma dor de cabeça
a idéia é exatamente esta por muito que
nós tínhamos proximidade com a vida de
alguém
nós nunca conseguimos compreender que o
aumento é que o que essa experiência
física sua experiência do corpo procure
alguma forma nós temos sistemas nervosos
usa parte enquanto indivíduos sujeitos e
que os impedem de viver a dor do outro
ou experiência física do outro nesse
sentido essa galera parecem ser
particularmente rica com os coloca por
apps um outro mundo sensorial que nós só
podemos imaginar que o trecho não
sensorial atravessa uma situação de
saramago que usa o seu ensaio sobre a
cegueira em que o bicho uma certa
passagem como toda a gente fez na sua
abrangência jogar o jogo do esse foi o
céu estará conclusão
o cabo cinco minutos com os olhos
fechados o que seria sem dúvida uma
trégua aos graça se não jogar um jogo e
se for cego e se chama os olhos
nós vamos ter a noção que essa era uma
profunda de graça mas a questão é que
pensar sobre as férias e magda
fala sobre as heranças que envolve que
acho que nós temos sobre a cegueira um
ensaio para ser extra mago fala deste
nosso sofrimento o mesmo faz porque
cegueira é uma tragédia e portanto surge
como uma riquíssima no bafo para
explicar a ignorância a organização as
trevas um fundo todos os finalmentes
costas vão encontrar na entrada qualquer
dicionário sobre os que é curioso pensar
sobre a série faz aqui o mesmo que
existe na nossa sociedade não é site da
sobraci dera a experiência das pessoas
cegas não existem não há uma única
pessoa séria num ensaio sobre a cegueira
é um ensaio que é produzido através das
experiências de quem vê e pensarmos a
cegueira como algo diferente uma
tragédia
no fundo eu via as pessoas sérias e
ouvir as suas experiências quando acabar
a licenciatura em antropologia e curi
fazer um trabalho tempo de pensar vou
fazer um trabalho sobre a primeira
reação que houve era manter um assunto
que não temos um desafio muito difícil
tenho 22 anos é e na altura a minha
única grande diferença sofrimento era
ter acabado um namoro ainda que não está
a atravessar
mas não tinha digamos assim na minha
experiência e biografia e pessoal é que
ela vai ensinar de dor e sofrimento que
eu achava que era necessário para lidar
com um tema tão confusa quando chegar à
assunção 27 a capa
tudo que eu vi era que eu tinha um
conjunto preconceitos pouco tem a ver
com experiência daquelas pessoas que as
pessoas venham mostrávamos com shows de
talentos pessoais não conseguir emprego
como uma frequência normal como toda a
gente e eu percebi então que evita falar
com preconceito de que o que eu também
pesava sobre o que seria a experiência
das pessoas sérias porque nós pensamos
acelera como a tragédia
nós pensamos que uma questão muito
simples é que os nossos corpos pensão
nós usamos nossos corpos como tubo de
ensaio você terá que preencher o outro
nós produzimos uma forma da empatia que
o mpt roni é mesmo aquilo que nós
produzimos quando haver um programa de
televisão e nos aparece alguém tem uma
fratura exposta ou alguém que te faz um
corto nós viramos a cara para o nosso
corpo como que as vistas a aumentar a
experiência do outro mas nós falharmos
na nossa empatia é nossa empatia induz
em erro indo o dinheiro em vários
sentidos
primeiro porque nós nunca podemos
perceber o que a experiência de uma
pessoa sendo cega nunca viu alguém para
quem essa idéia não representa uma perda
é que os minutos com os chatos nós só
conseguimos imaginar a experiência de
perder enviadas cara não conseguisse não
conseguimos imaginar o que seja alguém
viver no mundo com outras referências um
igualmente rico sensorialmente rico mas
que não têm a dimensão da perda
por outro lado nós não conseguimos
imaginar como acontece em muitas doenças
degenerativas alguém que faz se dando ao
longo de décadas
jorge luis borges e china em 1859 dizia
eu comecei a jogar no dia em que che
existe uma passagem santista não
levantar aí em que jorge luiz rocha mais
velho e cerro fala com versão mais jovem
jorge rocha em evidência e disney sabe
quando em verso fica cheia mas não
preocupa
essa era uma coisa trágica é comum em
terceiro grau e 50 que mendes bota
escrevi a sua experiência das carreiras
experiências em um momento trágico sem
uma perda abrupta permitiu que eu sou da
paz que eu possa aprender novas línguas
pelo modo como guião para eu escrever
essa ironia suprema ser o diretor da
biblioteca do ano as áreas
quando eu já não conseguir vôos estavam
sob o seu domínio mas há um outro
momento a partir do qual nós não
conseguimos prender perceber a
experiência da guerra
é verdade que entrevistei muitas pessoas
que tinham acabado de chegar e e e o
pulsar aquilo que é a vivência uma
tragédia pessoas fizeram seu uso pessoas
prenderam referências no mundo e
portanto sem que o instituídas de suas
referências
e talvez aí essa nossa experiência de
fechar os olhos no gelo nos ajuda a
compreender a experiência da série mas
não nos ajuda a compreender como é que
uns constrói ou unb anos e ao longo de
décadas e como é que esse mundo ganhe
novas referências porque alguém que
segue em alguém que vai reencontrar os
termos de resistência ao longo do tempo
às vezes é preciso fazer o seu uso sem
dúvida ficar em casa chave deprimido por
ventura
mas depois que descobre que existe um
mundo feito de outros sentidos e
portanto esse tempo nós não temos porque
os nossos corpos ea nossa empatia não
permite que nós chegamos temos tons nós
somos traídos pela convicção de que a
partir do nosso corpo nós podemos
conhecer as outras vidas
nós somos traídos pela convicção que
vida do outro em campinas na pequena
variável da nossa própria experiência
nesse sentido surgem as palavras porque
esta possibilidade de viver a vida dos
outros nem possibilidade de evitar o
corpo de uma outra pessoa
nós ficamos dependentes das palavras
precárias como eu acham na pobreza da
linguagem que têm dificuldade em
exprimir o sentido o corpo e muitas
vezes sentido à vida e esse é o desafio
que nós temos
como dizia o foi mas cesariny nós
jonas molhadas nós vivemos dentro das
muralhas
o desafio portanto é tentar fugir os
constrangimentos das nossas culturas
o encontro de culturas menos certas os
seus sentidos
o nosso desafio é ser do conforto dos
nossos corpos pra perceber através do
nosso silêncio e da nossa capacidade de
ouvir e de perceber aquilo que têm ações
em gestos e palavras os outros nos dizem
acerca daquilo que vivem ea certeza
daquilo que fazem o desafio é perceber
que temos que inventar o lugar justiça
social onde antes moravam antes com isso
as tragédias
as palavras são tudo aquilo que temos
para chegar ao corpo e à vida do outro é
assim que temos a paciência o tempo e
coragem